now that the the fan base is growing and  a lot more people are finding out  like i said at the beginning you're  opening it up yourself to so many  different opinions and  i think you do in certain ways have to  have quite tough skin to deal with a lot  of people kind of saying different  things about you know your songs or your  performance or your videos or whatever  it may be but  i've kind of taken criticism good or bad  and i've turned it into something that i  can always learn from and something that  makes me stronger and something that  hopefully the next time i do something  it will  i don't know i'll grow and  everything has happened so fast that  i've done a lot of my learning on the  job